donne le ton. Allez voir, sur le
terrain travailler très fort
mais ce n'est pas évident.
- C'est un dimanche parfait
pour faire campagne.
Un soleil radieux réchauffe
Trois-Rivières, la capitale
de la Mauricie. Pour Yves
Lévesque, qui l'a dirigée
pendant 17 ans, l'occasion est
inespérée, la Ville inaugure
son nouveau colisé.
YVES LEVESQUE, candidat, PCC
Trois-Rivières,
- Effectivement, ça tombe bien.
C'est un des projets qu'on a
fait à Trois-Rivières.
Parce qu'on en a fait beaucoup.
- Arrivé troisième en 2019,
dans une course où l'écart entre
la 1re et la 3e place était
de seulement 3 %, l'ex-maire,
reconnu pour être aussi
populaire que polarisant,
n'a pas dit son dernier mot.
- On connait l'homme, mais le
parti puis tout ça, je ne peux
pas dire si c'est mieux ou pas.
- T'as pas choisi le bon parti.
- Non, c'est le meilleur,
si je suis là, c'est parce que
c'est le meilleur. Si t'as
confiance en moi, écoute bien :
le Bloc sert à rien puis
le parti libéral, c'est un parti
de la gauche maintenant.
- Bonjour, j'aimerais vous
présenter René Villemure,
candidat du Bloc québécois ici,
dans Trois-Rivières.
- Peu connu dans la région,
l'éthicien René Villemure espère
succéder à sa collègue Louise
Charbonneau qui avait créé
la surprise en remportant
Trois-Rivières au coude à coude
avec libéraux et conservateurs
il y a deux ans.
- Bien, il est sympathique,
mais je ne le connais pas.
- Si comme partout au pays,
l'économie et l'environnement
préoccupent les trifluviens,
la question posée au chef
bloquiste lors du débat
en anglais n'est pas passée
inaperçue dans cette ville
où 96 % de la population
est francophone.
RENÉ VILLEMURE, candidat, BQ
Trois-Rivières, Qc
- On était hier à rencontrer des
citoyens puis c'était la
première chose, même de loin,
pout-pout sur la rue. Alors
c'est un effet notable.
- Le débat en anglais,
j'ai trouvé ça dégeulasse
un petit peu.
- Ça a confirmé des choix.
- En tant que québécois,
c'est sûr que ça nous parle
un peu plus, mais on va décider
la journée du vote.
- Je m'appelle Martin Francoeur,
je suis le candidat du parti...
- On vous reconnait.
- Même avec le masque?
- Même s'il bénéficie d'une
certaine notoriété, la campagne
du libéral, ex-éditorialiste
au quotidien local, est plombée
par ses critiques passées sur
Justin Trudeau et Chirstia
Freeland. Martin Francoeur
insiste. Après 28 ans dans
l'opposition, il est temps
pour Trois-Rivières d'avoir
une voix à Ottawa.
MARTIN FRANCOEUR, candidat, PLC
Trois-Rivières, Qc
- On a la chance de faire
avancer Trois-Rivières puis d'un
autre côté, il y a un adversaire
conservateur qui se présente
dans un parti aux idées
rétrogrades.
- Bonjour, vous allez bien ?
- Oui.
- Je peux vous voler une petite
minute de votre temps?
- Pas trop loin derrière
le peloton de tête,
Adis Smidzija, arrivé
au Canada en tant que réfugié
de la Bosnie-Herzégovine
à l'âge de 9 ans, aimerait bien
se faufiler en tête.
ADIS SIMIDZIJA, candidat, NPD
Trois-Rivières, Qc
- Je la rappelle toujours,
on est la septième
circonscription avec le plus
faible taux de revenu médian
par ménage.
- Le néodémocrate, qui se
présente comme le défenseur
des minorités et des plus
vulnérables, incarne un certain
renouveau politique.
- Nous, ce qu'on veut,
c'est faire sortir le vote.
- Conservateurs sous Mulroney,
bloquistes pendant presque deux
décennies, puis emportée par
la vague orange, l'humeur
des électeurs trifluviens est
souvent un bon indicateur des
grandes tendances nationales.
À quelques jours des élections,
les indécis sont encore
nombreux. Bien malin qui
pourrait prédire quelle couleur
prendra Trois-Rivières
et le reste du pays.
Ici Amélie Desmarais,
Radio-Canada, Trois-Rivi